Hey youtubers it’s Charlie, I just got to
see Days of Future Past so this is going to
be my review of the movie.
And because it changes the X-Men Universe
in a really interesting way I’m going to
do a breakdown of the new Timeline and the
post-credits scene.
Remember when you go see it to stay through
all of the credits.
If you’re finding me for the first time,
now that we’re in the middle of summer movie
season I’m going to be doing more and more
big movie videos like Guardians of The Galaxy,
How To Train Your Dragon and Planet of The
Apes.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
And if there’s a movie you really want me
to make a video for just let me know in the
comments.
So because most of you probably haven’t
seen X-Men yet I’m going to start with a
non-spoilery review, then I’ll do spoilers
where I talk about my top 5 moments and how
the movie fits into the franchise as well
as the post-credits scene.
Don’t worry, I’ll tell you when the spoilers
start.
So right off the bat I really liked this movie,
it’s a very very different type of superhero
movie from Winter Soldier which just came
out a little while ago.
I thought of it as being a revisionist history
political thriller that had superheros in
it.
Like they could have made this movie without
any superheroes or time travel and it would
still have been an interesting story.
Which is one of the reasons I think they asked
Bryan Singer to return and direct it.
He does thrillers really well.
And he does ensemble films really well.
One of the big differences between this movie
and the Marvel films is that the cast is so
much bigger.
They had so many characters, that it takes
a lot of work to make sure you don’t forget
what the actual story is.
And Bryan Singer did a really good job of
maintaining the throughline of the X-Men trying
to change the past.
They did this really interesting thing with
the cinematography where they change the way
the film looks when you go back into the past.
The movie takes place in two different times.
In the past it’s sometime during the 70s
when Richard Nixon was president.
So they use old timey looking film footage
whenever newsreels are playing.
I mentioned revisionist history and that’s
what a lot of the movie is.
It weaves the X-Men into real life historical
events in really interesting ways.
So a lot of you will laugh at some of the
changes the movie makes too other famous people
from the 70s.
Even though it didn’t lean too hard on big
special effects there are a healthy number
of big action set pieces.
They pretty much spoiled the biggest one in
all the trailers.
So there’s no real surprise there.
And they don’t get too crazy with explaining
all the new powers we see on screen.
Let’s talk about characters though, because
that’s really where the movie shines.
Yes it was fun seeing the original X-Men on
screen with the First Class versions and Patrick
Stewart gets a lot of good Professor X speechifying
moments, but my favorite performances were
from Evan Peters as Quicksilver and Hugh Jackman.
Evan Peters was definitely the most fun to
watch.
After this movie it really feels like the
most visible actors in the franchise are Jennifer
Lawrence and Hugh Jackman.
Combine them together and you get what Robert
Downey Jr is to Marvel.
Hugh Jackman was originally going to retire
from being Wolverine after this movie, but
he totally just backtracked and is now doing
another spinoff which will be like an Old-Man
Logan film and the next X-Men sequel Apocalypse.
So now it’s time to talk about my top 5
moments and all the timeline changes.
So careful for spoilers in case you haven’t
seen it yet.
But here we go.
Number 5 - The Post Apocalyptic Future
It’s always fun to see the end point, like
skipping ahead to the last page in a book.
If you’d watched the 90s X-Men cartoon,
they did an X-Men Age of Apocalypse storyline
with some of the new characters we see in
the movie like Bishop.
Days of Future Past is a whole different storyline
from Age of Apocalypse but visually the world
of the future looks very similar.
Everything ends up in a pile of rubble.
It was fun to see the future tech too.
Like the new Quintjet.
I can only wonder what that power source was.
Maybe like a small fusion reactor?
The sentiels too were pretty cool.
If you didn’t catch it.
They were mimicking Mystique’s powers to
adapt to different mutant powers.
That’s why they could use fire against Bobby
or Ice against Sunspot.
A few of them killed X-Men with physical attacks.
But it seemed like the most popular kill shot
power was Cyclops Eye Blast.
Number 4 - The World of 70s
One of my favorite things about the movie
was the way they made everything look.
Like everyone had Wolverine’s sideburns.
I’m just kidding, but if you’ve ever heard
stories about how New York City turned into
a dump in the 70s and 80s, that’s kind of
what I thought of when they showed all the
X-Men.
It’s like after the 60s period in First
Class and the Vietnam war, everything just
went to hell, major characters have been laid
low.
Mystique has become this disillusioned angry
person and it seems like everyone just hates
themselves.
The biggest part of the movie is just the
call to action, people digging themselves
out of the graves they’ve all made for themselves.
Number 3 - Old Hugh Jackman In the 70s
So if it wasn’t clear, when he goes back
in time, his body hasn’t been infused with
Adamantium yet and he hadn’t met Stryker.
Which is why he freaks when he sees young
Stryker for the first time.
Hugh Jackman really is the face of the movie,
even if the plot mostly revolves around Jennifer
Lawrence.
They added just the
right amount of Logan jokes, using his healing
factor for comedy and putting up with things.
Of all the characters, he’s one of the few
who can say, they’ve heard every joke and
seen everything.
So logically he should be the least surprised
by everything.
I loved that the story gave him the burden
of calling everyone to action.
Patrick Stewart gave him a little help, but
for the most part Wolverine is the one who
rounds up the team and pushes the story forward.
And the great thing is that as much as they
change the timeline at the end of the movie,
his character is pretty much the same.
Same old grumpy Logan.
And I wouldn’t have it any other way.
Number 2 - Jennifer Lawrence
There’s a lot going on with Jennifer Lawrence
in the X-Men Movies and in real life.
As the older cast members start getting older,
she’s really going to become the face of
the franchise.
Like the mega star that they’ll use to market
it.
So as long as she keeps doing X-Men movies,
she’ll continue to be one of the central
characters.
The good thing about this is that she’s
a great actress and because Mystique is a
loner, she can align herself with the new
villain in the next X-Men movie, Apocalypse.
I’ll talk about that more in a sec, but
overall I think she had a stronger performance
than James McAvoy or Michael Fassbender.
and
my number 1 moment - The New Timeline
So many things to say about this.
What happened is they basically negated the
events of Wolverine Origins and X-3, the Brett
Ratner movie.
Which I am so happy about.
They didn’t throw away any of Bryan Singer’s
X-Men movies, so everyone is back.
But I think that all the future sequels will
mostly just be the new First Class cast members.
And as much as they changed history, a lot
of things still played out the same.
But I think they’ll address the continuity
more in future films.
But now it’s your turn, let me know what
your favorite moment was.
And what do you think about the new timeline?
I know I didn’t mention the big Magneto
action set piece, it was cool, but very predictable.
And they spoiled it in the trailer.
So it wasn’t as much of a WTF moment.
Post Credits Scene time.
As expected it was all about teasing the next
X-Men Sequel, X-Men Apocalypse.
And even though the main villain will be Apocalypse,
we could also see Mister Sinister and other
evil mutants.
If you want to learn more about Apocalypse,
you should read the X-Men Age of Apocalpyse
comic book and watch the 90s Cartoon.
The cartoon is on Netflix and tells a lot
of his backstory.
Essentially he’s been living in this X-Men
world for thousands of years.
So presumably, the movie will explain why
we haven’t seen him in any of the movies
yet if he’s so powerful.
I loved watching him use telikenesis to construct
the ancient pyramids.
What did I say about X-Men films being revisionist
history stories?
If it wasn’t clear, the scene was in ancient
egypt.
I think they pyramid he was building was the
Great Pyramid of Giza, which was constructed
at about 2560 BC.
So that gives you an idea for how old he is.
Essentially he’s immortal.
Much more so than Wolverine.
Wolverine isn’t immortal, he just heals
himself constantly.
So he ages really really slowly.
We can talk about Apocalypse more in another
video, but this weekend I’m working on a
few more bonus videos.
So be sure to subscribe to get everything.
And thanks again for your patience.
I’m traveling, so I’m working on a super
slow laptop with really awful wifi.
Right now click here for my breakdown of the
Guardians of The Galaxy trailer and click
here to learn all about Arrow Season 3 and
The Flash tv show.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!